this program is brought to you by Emory
University
this work on purge
seven years actually to where we are
today it started out long before I came
to Emory when I was still in New England
and working on recovery from brain
damage at a time in the 1970s early
1970s when no one was really thinking
that the brain that the adult brain
could recover from any kind of serious
damage was always thought to be a series
of tricks during that time they were
anecdotal and clinical reports in the
literature suggesting that women recover
better from brain injury from traumatic
brain injury and stroke than do males
and we began to follow that line of
investigation simply because it was it
was interesting to us in the context of
looking at recovery of function this was
long before we actually got interested
in progesterone percent but to cut to
the quick when we did that work in
laboratory animals we actually used
laboratory rats with we damaged the
frontal cortex which is very similar to
the types of injury that people get when
they go through the windshield of a car
for example and we found that indeed
females did recover better than males
but what we noticed as we progress with
our work was that it depended on where
the female was in her estrus cycle at
the time of an injury the estrus cycle
in a rat is like the menstrual cycle in
a human female and what we discovered
through a series of experiments was that
when the animals were high in
progesterone and we could measure this
very precisely when they were high in
progesterone at the time of injury the
outcome was much better than if the same
injury occurred when they were high in
estrogen so then we began to rule out
what would you know how did this work in
the animals that were high and
progesterone at the time of injury they
virtually had no brain swelling no
cerebral edema this is a major cause of
death in a lot of people that suffer
from traumatic brain injury so this was
a pretty exciting finding and those
initial that initial work actually got
published in the journal science and
when we gave males similar doses to what
we were giving to females we worked out
all those dose levels and stuff we found
that the male's performed just as well
as the females despite the fact that in
normal males with brain injury that
didn't get any treatment their outcomes
were much worse than females in general
that's because
males make much less progesterone one of
the things that I do want to point out
it's that is that progesterone it's not
just a female home and that's really a
big mistake in thinking about it that
way
males make it we make it in the brain
just like females do we just make a lot
less of it most people thought it was
nuts they didn't believe that what they
then called a female hormone basically
involved in reproduction could have
these kinds of beneficial effects on
brain function I had moved to Emory
University I came here as the Dean of
the graduate school I had my lab and was
working in the lab as well as doing the
administration and I got to know dr. art
Kellerman who was then the chair of
emergency medicine and he brought on
board a young physician by the name of
dr. David Wright who came to the lab and
started working with me as an emergency
medicine doc and together we began to
demonstrate more mechanisms of how
progesterone works and by that point we
had enough data not only from our lab
but from a couple of other labs around
the world to begin to think maybe we
really ought to look at this in a
clinical setting because the results
were so consistent that injections given
anywhere within one to 24 hours after an
injury could produce these very dramatic
reductions in cerebral edema an
inflammatory process and most
importantly in functional behavioral
benefit or outcomes in the patient's
given state state of standard of
practice care which is the best that
anybody could do and those patients
given standard of practice care but no
progesterone the mortality rate was
about 30 31 % and the patient's given
progesterone the mortality rate with
severe brain injuries was dropped to
something like 13% so it was a very
substantial difference in outcome of
survival at 30 days but more importantly
the patients in the moderate group who
got progesterone did much much better on
functional outcome on measures of
different neural cognitive measures of
outcome on the basis of those results
and by the time we got around to doing
further clinical work which I'll tell
you about they then was about a hundred
that were about a hundred and fifty
publications from some 30 labs around
the world and 22 different injury models
and four species including people
showing the beneficial effects of
progesterone in the treatment
traumatic brain injury in both men and
women most of the patients were actually
men so taking all those data together
they then went ahead the folks here in
emergency medicine consortium with some
17 other major level 1 trauma centers
around the country applied for what's
called a phase 3 clinical trial this
became known as Pro Tech 3 and Pro Tech
3 is a much larger trial it involves
1,200 patients obviously if it works
this then becomes the standard of
practice of care for for head trauma
pretty much across the world we think we
should be able to move this treatment to
stroke in the next couple of years if
the data continues to show such promise
and it really is dramatically good I
think the thing to keep in mind and what
what led us to all this is that if you
think about progesterone as a
developmental hormone it really makes a
lot of sense as to why it's working as
well as it does when women become
pregnant their progesterone levels
increase tenfold 15 fold over what they
normally carry when they're not and
progesterone levels stay high all during
development and gestation if you have
this home on protecting the fetus it's
not surprising to me that repair
processes if one stops and thinks about
it a little bit that the processes of
tissue repair whether it's in the brain
or any other organ of the body are kind
of similar they're not identical to but
they're kind of similar to what takes
place in development so a lot of the
properties that an aid in repair of
damaged brain tissue are also playing a
role in development any type of brain
injury such as the type that we're
looking at in laboratory animals or in
people or stroke for example it's not
just a brain disorder
these are systemic diseases when you
have a brain injury almost every organ
of your body is going to be affected and
so you need a you need an agent a drug a
hormone whatever you want to call that
effects these toxic processes throughout
the entire organism not just focusing on
one small part of the brain and so
that's what that's where progesterone
really shines as well and is why one of
the reasons why I think it's very likely
to be successful in these clinical
trials so one of the other things you
want to be able to do is stop those long
term detrimental processes and I think
that progesterone is a reg
to a hormone does all of these things
and we were just lucky enough to to
stumble upon it as at an interesting
time when no one else was thought it
would be a feasible type of work to do
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University